OK Hello everyone.
Thank you for coming to the session, Lighting Talks
CNS 428.
So my name is Juraj Mahapatra.
I'm the principal specialist solutions architect. I
focus on Amazon Bedrock and Agent Core,
and I focus on startup customers. I've been with AWS
for 6 years, a little bit more than 6 years,
and this aspect of what we're going to talk
about as human in the loop,
it is applicable to all workflows,
microservices, and now we are talking about
gentic systems and why this is useful.
So just a show of hands.
I asked this question before, but how many
of you are using agents in production today?
None. How many of you are using
uh inferencing, LLM influencing in
production today? So most of them.
So what I wanted to show is
How did we evolve from normal
assistance
to actually autonomous agents
and why autonomous agents are important in this era?
And where human in the loop is important to
implement
and how can you implement which
HITL with some of the mechanics,
some of the key takeaways and
a couple of resources that I find very useful
for you. OK,
so as this progression, this is
a timeline
that shows you like how we started with
simple
generative AI assistance and mostly
towards chatbots functionality,
but we slowly evolved over time.
But right now we're talking about all the way in the
right,
where we are talking about agentic AI
systems.
Agentic AI system doesn't mean that it has
to be front-ended by a chatbot,
right? You can invoke agents
asynchronously. Let's say something happened
in your system,
it omitted an event, and you have an
event subscriber
that can go and work with multiple agents,
right? So agents can work
behind the scenes. It doesn't have to be a customer
sitting at the front on a chat board.
So that's where we are
As and when you go right, you will see
we are focusing
higher degree of human oversight
to low degree of human oversight when
you're moving towards autonomous systems.
However,
there is a concept of ownership in every
aspect,
like when you build applications.
And you have agents in place.
When you run them in production and something goes
wrong, you can't blame an agent.
It's the developer or it's the person who
owns that application
has to take the ownership, right?
So that's where
agentic AI with some degree
of human in the loop is very important to
build. So before we jump into
how and when HITL should
be implemented,
I wanted to give you a background of how we
started with model inferencing,
specifically on AWS and where we are
right now.
And that will give a clear picture of why we
should think about human in the loop right
from the very beginning when we build agentic
AI systems.
Couple of years ago, if you have to build,
or if you have to use a model on AWS,
these are the options you had. So
as a user, you'll come, you need a
compute layer where you have to run a model for influencing,
and some of the options for you were Sage Maker.
Today we have Bedrock.
Uh, you can run your model getting from hugging
face, and you can run it on ICS, EC2, or
EKS.
And then this is a simple example of
a chat GPT if you think about it, right? You
have a model,
you can ask questions, you get answers back,
so on and so forth.
Then we evolved into systems where you need
some context or some
history to maintain, to be maintained in that session
or in that discussion
so that you can get better results,
right? That's why we talked about having a
persistent store
where you can
purchase some of the chat history
and then when the LLM is coming back with
a response, it can understand the chat
history and provide a response.
Then we evolved our systems to
build
contextual
responses,
right, with chat history as well.
So now you have.
A user calling
a level of compute
that talks to a model,
but before talking to a model it has to use
a vector store to get additional context
for your organization or anything. This is simple drag.
Get the vector embeddings and
augment that embeddings to the
LLM to get a better response.
So this is where we were.
Excuse me, in this scenario.
All of those contextual data is
mostly static in nature, so I have my
organizational standards,
I want to bring my architectural standards,
and if I want to use that as part of a vector
store, these are all
static data that I have to deal with.
But what if you actually want to leverage
the power of LLMs with real-time
data? Like, that's
where the discussion around
tools
and agents come into the picture,
right? In addition to doing
RAG or LLM inferencing,
if you have to deal with real-time data, you
have to build something like this
with agents
and a bunch of tools that can go out on
your behalf, call an API,
uh, execute a database query,
and get real-time information,
and that information will be augmented to
the context of the last language model
to do some work,
right? Now
this evolves because when you
start building agents and tools,
the very next step comes into the picture is
how can I secure the setup?
How can I get observability, because when you build
APIs or application, you need that observability
in place.
So with agent and tools you will still
need the same observability in practice.
So you need some inbound authentication
on who can call the agents,
outbound authentication on who the agent
can call to.
So on and so forth, and then you need guard rails
around bedrock,
some observability using cloud watch or
third party providers, so on and so forth.
This also evolves when you think about
concepts like.
Right? So we are evolving from
simple LLM influencing to how we are building
agents today with MCP servers.
And if you look at it now, the big picture,
how you do
agents on AWS, it will look
like this.
Which will have agents running on a set of
compute, some memory
that maintains history and long-term memory.
MCP server integrations for external tools
that you want to use
and also A2A integration. If
you know A2A is a protocol that
Google came up with
for agent to agent communication and
while they're doing all of these things,
you need observability with travel
watch or third party tools.
So This is
one agent.
We're talking about capability of one agent
that talks to multiple MCP servers
or tools or or other agents
with some capability of memory and
identity.
However, when you want to run in production,
the actual production scenario will look like this,
right? So you'll have an
agent in your purview, but then
multiple agents in your department, in your
organization, and then you have to integrate with
external tools, so on and so forth.
So you can
imagine the complexity that you have to deal with, the chaos
of this whole setup that you have to deal with,
right? So that's where you
have to figure out like if you build systems,
how and when in which areas that you have
to build human in the loop capabilities.
Right? So you have to
find those checkpoints
where human judgment is very necessary
and if possible, whatever
human insight that was given
goes back to the AI system
so that it can do a better judgment next time.
So what are those points? So,
excuse me. Think about high stakes
decision points.
So I'll take an example. Like if a doctor
has to subscribe prescribe
a medicine to a patient.
You need some intervention and
not rely on the entire agentic system
to build a prescription for the agent, right?
The doctor has to provide
some capabilities to, OK,
this is a good medicine I can prescribe.
Then there will be cases where you
have to deal with irreversible actions.
What if
money gets debited from one account to the other
account, which you cannot undo?
What if you
completed a transaction which you cannot undo?
This is where those are the high touch points
where a human in the loop will be very
influential.
What about regulatory compliance?
There are countries and compliance standards
where a human oversight is always needed.
So finding out those places in the setup,
you will have to
add some checkpoints where a human can come
and provide a decision to move
forward. Most
important part is the trust building phase. So let's say
if you're starting new with agentic
AI,
it will be really good to have human
aspect in the entire setup
so that you are building trust
with the system.
Once you see that the human is actually
repeating the same task
and it has figured out that the AI or the
agent is actually building
what it is supposed to do, then you can slowly
remove the human intervention part out, so.
So this is the trust building part is where
if you're doing a proof of concept, if
you're starting with agents, then it will become
very easy to
start with human in the loop and then go from there.
Plus there will be some edge cases
and some uh uh ambiguity
where you will definitely need
human in the loop, where,
where, wherever it is necessary.
So, going back to the big picture.
There will be areas where you need.
Human in the loop where you're dealing with let's say MCP
server integration
or A2A integration with different agents
or finally when you're sending responses
to the customer,
right, you need some oversight to see whether, OK,
everything is OK
now we should be good to send responses back
to the user
or call it completing a task.
So what are the,
now, now that we talked about where human in the loop
is required,
where are the cases where human in the loop can be
avoided? Like let's say you have a case where
you have
confidence
in the threshold that you have set.
So let's say the agent came up with some
response and the confidence score is
higher.
That's where you can
avoid human being in the loop.
If you maintain high audit trails
and you go through those matrices
and you know that the agent is doing or the multi-agent
system is doing whatever it is supposed to do,
then you can slowly remove the human aspect
from the whole setup.
If you build a feedback loop as I
was talking earlier,
If the human can feed it back to the system,
then eventually
you will tend to removing the human aspect
from the entire setup.
And this will give you a
good process to gracefully degrade.
When human aspects are not required
anymore, right?
So what we're
talking about here is a progressive autonomy.
So you start with the highest level of
control with humans in the place,
but you slowly progress toward getting the
full autonomy when you have built the trust in the system
and for your clients and for your customers.
If you want to build human in the loop aspect,
in the case of MCP, MCP provides
this capability called elicitations. If you look
at this example,
if the request is
what is the flight status, then the MCP
server will ask a question.
Give me a flight number, then I'll be providing you
a flight status.
So this is the core capability of MCP as the
protocol, elicitations.
You can use it.
If you're using step functions as
a service to build workflows,
then step functions has this capability of wait
for callback.
The step functions workflow can wait for you
until an approval or a task
token that is sent back with a success message,
and then it'll go. So this is how it works.
When you ask for a token to be sent externally.
The token will be sent through different applications
or to an approver,
and if the approver says, OK,
everything looks good.
Then
the the token is sent back
and then the step functions will resume the
workflow execution
and it'll go to the next steps.
Now, if you have heard the keynote earlier, we
talked about
durable functions in lambda also,
right? So durable functions will
do the same, uh, similar uh
work what step functions has to provide.
If you're using tools like line graph
for your agents.
Some of the capabilities include like this, you can have
a human aspect
if a response is coming back from LLM
and the human can approve, if it approves,
then it goes to node B or
the graph node B or A,
and then it goes to graph node C if
there is a disapproval.
You can change the state behind the scenes
if a human is in place. So if a human says,
I'm getting an input which says F bar,
now I want to change that
to
bars, and then the next node will get
the latest updated value for the
underlying state.
So these are, these are the ways where a human can
intervene
and
change the course of action that the agent was supposed
to take. The last one is a human
can intervene and say whether I want to execute a
tool or I don't want to, or should I
execute a different tool.
This is in Landgraf.
If you're building interagent communications with MCP
and A2A, then there
are other capabilities. So if you take about
an example of a travel agent,
here is an example which I built using API
gateway, and A2A is the protocol,
which is A2A client in a lambda function,
calls a weather agent, which is again
API gate an API gateway with A2A
server behind the scenes,
and the A2A server sends a push notification
back to travel agents saying
what is the weather right now.
At this point in time I can
Put some HITL
aspect of it, either using step functions
or other capabilities,
and then I feedback that information to a state
that the lambda can use, the
ATA client can use, or I can send responses
back directly to the user.
So this is another example.
So now
The other aspect of
I talked about is when human in the loop
will slowly
go away when you're building autonomous systems, right?
So as continuous
agent evaluation grows,
you will see the human in the loop aspect will slowly
reduce. Now if you've heard the keynote,
we talked about agent core
evaluations in preview mode.
So that is if you're running agents on
agent core,
then agent core evaluation is something that
you can use.
To make sure that you get more autonomy
and less human intervention.
So as and when you see
the evaluation
maturity grows, the percentage grows
in the x axis,
your human in the loop aspect will grow down.
So overall what we're talking
about
is
When you want human oversight, and you will need
it in different places, that's where
you need those critical decision gatekeeping
capabilities.
That's where you need humans.
If you have workflows that build
and have errors that you have to recover
from, you can have a human insight
or human presence in the place to
provide you some capabilities to recover from
those errors.
You want to build trust and transparency. I talked
about this progressive autonomy, right?
You start with
human controls, and as and when you grow and
mature in your agenttic setup or multi-agent
setup, you can build the
trust and the transparency, plus
having those agent evaluations in place
will help you.
And then most importantly, gracefully degradation,
so things break
in production
and our CTO also mentioned that in
multiple keynotes that things
will break
if you have a capability to fall
back and gracefully degrade.
Why not have a human in the
whole set up
so that
the trustworthiness will still be alive
and the human can decide how to degrade this
whole setup gracefully.
So, there are some resources here.
The QR code will have all the information.
This is the blog that I wrote on
uh Agent AI using AWS Servius.
There are some technical papers, most importantly,
the one from Harvard.
That talks about the human algorithm
Centaur.
The concept of a centaurian system,
which is half human and half horse
is well
mentioned here in this Howard paper, so I
would encourage you to go read that
and how eventually we should move
towards building that Centaurion system
so that the human and the machines or
the AI agents will symbiotically
work properly together
without hampering each other.
It's a sample application and then in the GitHub
that I built uh using
the lambda functions example that I showed,
a travel agent and weather agent which uses A2A
client and server.
You can definitely check that out and
add a human in the loop aspect.
So, yep, this
is the lightning talk for you,
and if you have questions, we can head
down and we can discuss more,
but uh.
The resources are here to check out.
There are resources in the QR code.
It also talks about different sessions that I did
earlier around Agent EKI and AWS Servius.
So please check them out.
And with that,
thank you everyone
for being here.